in 7576 new york there was a very cool
disco culture before there was ever a
saturday night people robert said
this is a hundred million dollar movie
robert was the agent for the who cream
and the bg's
he understood music and could see beyond
a hit record
this was a chance to build his empire
robert is transitioning into producing
movies
they signed john travolta two three
picture deal
but we didn't have any pictures to
support it
robert was pitching this little disco
movie
trumpet did not know how it would be
cast he didn't know what the script
would be he just knew a fabulous story
which had global appeal was right there
and robert saw the soundtrack as being
the killer ingredient this studio wasn't
interested in soundtracks
the album has sold more than 10 million
copies paramount never had a piece of
the album
i had no idea what we had
i didn't even know it was a musical
i don't think anybody who foresaw the
phenomenon of this movie other than
robert stigwin and john travolta
one of robert's great achievements is to
wake up the synergy between records and
film
[Applause]
[Music]
you